Brady KCK played in his first home opener as
an a was Senator his second NHL game scored two
against the Philadelphia Flyers his first two NHL
goal he's going to look to make some impact here
on home ice this afternoon to try and get them
the first win of the Season here's Andre with
it rings that back around bouncing puck in front
Swept Away Now rebound chance and that's lifted
wide by Zach m h with a full compliment forwards
after playing one short against Carolina long shot
chck scores Jacob chck wires at home and grabs
the [Applause] leg he going to roll into Carter
heart he's going to take a swipe at it but it
ends up in the back of the net as Chan fires
it off the post but earlier in the play had an
opportunity for Carter Hart to settle that down
he pops it back in and chck in a Rolling Puck he
grabs it on his stick off his stick off the post
and in and the Ottawa Senators Le for branstrom
that's the blue line that's knocked down laid
back across fby with a quick shot and the stop
made by forsberg on the turnover by branstrom
turnover up the wall here branstrom is going to
just feather it up and it's kept in little scene
pass now it changes sides Bar's going to fire
it towards the net but look at where forsberg
is ter not too shabby that department himself
plays it back down to kubalik kubalik for teraso
cross for Sanderson back for kual got a hard shot
there by CH rocket it just wide turn up by ainson
didn't good bye now Sanderson back for teraso
in shoots that was blocked by Sanai Sanderson
lays it back around terce SLE back across CH Sho
scor CH begin Ottawa leads do [Applause] nothing
and the power play strikes again exchange
here between Jake Sanderson and Tera senko
Sanderson absorbs contact now watch Tera senko
take some ice for himself he's going to skate
down the middle of the ice you have to defend
that cuz he's a shooter rolls his wrist at the
last second puts it on a t and Jacob Cham does
the rest and then the little peek towards the
bench there letting them know hey sanheim swings
that back to Forester down the for Forester across
to sanheim back for Forester Watton shoots forur
save rebound score it's KY on the five on three
and Philadelphia's on the board you see the s's
getting a little tired goes off the left pad of
Anton forsberg as they change sides and now watch
left P right out to the middle and conne is wide
open for that rebound down as he hammers it home
as ardam Zu on the rotation little late to try and
get underneath the stick but it's the Flyers that
make this a 2-1 game with 309 left and 44 seconds
left connecting three goals the first two games
for Travis connecting lost the handou drop back
chose him a hard shot rebound and heart turns out
away another chance for Joseph lifts that down to
BS Matthew Joseph gets an opportunity Drake bson
going to push back the defender Joseph throws it
towards the net Hart can't get the initial
offering and then Joseph tries to go yeah
she runs the family there and it great you know
what those commercials are amazing shows a lot of
Personality it goes ahead to Forester being
defended by Cher to S out away stla long lead
pass to kachuck Rick W goes to Theo th Drew
in shoots and Hart makes a stop on that and
this is the second unit out there which
scored the Ottawa power play goal here's
the man who scored it CH bangs that back
to Sanderson across to teraso teraso back
to Sanderson [Applause] scores a rocket
from Jes Sanderson a power play goal it's
[Music] 3-1 the power play contributes so much
two of the three Auto goals today have been scored
the man [Music] advantage so a little breathing
room and now walking is yor the CH scores first
shot in over 14 minutes for Philadelphia and
cam York makes it once again a one-goal game
and it's just advancing the puck now watch
connecting he wants that puck he stretches
out coverage he gets the puck and it's a touch
play so York's going to just chip it over to
connecting and he just touches it into space
and York gets it back it's a rolling pockets
on his stick off his stick and he here the the
post again posting in over the glove of Anton
forsburg and we've got a 3-2 [Music] Game Face
Off one by the Flyers connecting looks down to
York who has the second Philadelphia go that
pass is picked off by giru for kachak in comes
Brady KCK with clo jaru that pass broken up by
Sanai now pick offu CH scores bring a Chuck from
pju and ottawa's back up by [Music] two get the
inside position lifts the stick and puts it on a
t for kachuck he knows they in the dying seconds
of the period you got to make something happen
very quickly he's able to pickpocket and use his
physicality on sanheim and you see how excited
kachuck is on this play kachuck gets available
and knows that jeru is going to get it to
ala Ed seven goalies last year yeah and cam
cin missed the first five weeks that pressed
Anton forsburg into a situation where he's
a good short-term starter but he's better
scla shabat back for scla Miss fire that
shot knot BS it back around to zeru chops
it back to shabbat for spooka shoot to
the goal post stla back with it down a
kak szla giru Walker and shoots and heart
knock that away K Chuck knock to stick out
of the hands of stall the Flyers were hollering
about that St back to giru throws it back in
front the go oh a score knock home by stla
another Power Play goal it's [Applause] 52
and try and jam it in past Carter hard and
he sticks with it so it's j down to kachuck
and kachuck it's on his stick but he's got to
Pivot and turn and try and jam it away it's a
good initial right pad save but he bouns it
out of the air and elevates it over top of
Carter hard and then you see the the flex as he
scored two straight here for the Senators half
away halfway lost the handle threw
it back in front and forsburg makes
a good stop there in DeLorean here's how
that pile up started a little redirect by
delore solid save by forsberg
then delore is the GM of that
team stolen by Frost working in on zoo Frost shs
to the glov sa made by forsberg and on forsberg
and his first start of the year turns in a Dandy
glove stop connecting to Couer back for tippet
Ry goes to connect that pass disrupted by Kelly
York with a Chance another glove save by forsberg
tippet going to throw it to connect me through the
seam York's going to skate right into it a Rolling
Puck win the Stanley Cup this year yeah they're
a top tier team you knew they were was going to
take everything to beat them on the road but I
thought Ottawa beat themselves there were some
critical mistakes half away franois St Lon here's
the Chance by delore another qu saved by forsberg
halfway is going to go off here okay I think I've
set him on six times so here's C centers it and a
great chance there short-handed and with their
fourth straight home opener decisively 52 over
[Music]
Philadelphia